[Music]
as a working professional I feel the
only way to grow exponentially in your
career is by upskilling I believe it was
the perfect step for my professional
career I changed my career to main club
Computing with a 30 percent salary into
your bank hi I'm Hafiz I live in Bahrain
with my family and I work as a software
quality assurance professional at zero
one systems some time back I realized
that the technology in the cloud
computing field is advancing rapidly I
was always interested in this video so I
wanted to upskill myself in the same and
learn all the latest tools and
Technologies hence I decided to go for
the postgraduate program in cloud
computing from Simply learn
collaboration with call Tech I believe
it was the perfect step for my
professional carrier with the help of
these newly acquired skills I changed my
career to main club recruiting with a 30
percent salary implement
simply don't turn out to be a great
platform
I chose it over other platforms because
of its comprehensive curriculum also the
faculty is not much I have already
recommended a few of my colleagues and
friends what worked out significantly
well for me was the Blended learning
approach where I could learn at my own
pace with the help of re-recorded
material and also attend live classes on
weekends Australia
after completing my course my
performance at work and my confidence
into exponentially
now I can work much more efficiently I
feel I took the perfect step towards
achieving my long-term goal of becoming
a club
I believe I have been able to leverage
all my love needs from the course and I
am using them regularly
I believe a new technological Revolution
is coming at cloud computing will be a
major part of it
my advice to every working professional
would be to keep upgrading their skills
and improving themselves it is important
to take risks and keep challenging
oneself keep learning and keep growing